what is up everybody welcome back to
another graphing financial information
tutorial where we left off let's bring
that chart up we were plotting this
chart now obviously the day is a little
itty on it's kind of going under this
things over lapping the day but this is
up clearly the correct price here that
is the correct day even though we can't
see if we adjust the size of this window
it kind of stretches up but will it will
be coating it in to fix that in a moment
and you know we don't have a title
without any labels over a year so it's
not really a proper chart and also I'd
like to have gridlines so that's what
we're going to go ahead and do in this
video so close out of that and the first
thing I'd like to do is look let's set
up the grids
so here right underneath the last a x1
dot plot let's do a x1 grid and in
currencies just type in true that will
add a grid to what we're doing now the
next thing I'd like to do is we want to
add a title and the correct label so
we'll just do that down here and let's
say PLT dot X label and we're going to
say the X label is day and then PLT dot
y label for this we're going to its
stock price so now that we have the
labels let's bring up the graph again in
the grid so now it makes it a little bit
easier to read right we have the grid on
there it's real easy to line up the date
with you know the price at the time and
those I like as you hover it if you'll
notice down here in the corner you see
the information but if like your mouse
is over here it's still reading you
information but anyway um and just like
let's go through a couple quick things
again this is all covered in my
matplotlib tutorial series but let's go
over a couple things - how to use this
for one if you want to zoom in like two
different parts of the graph you can use
this like zoom in button and like let
and you make a square like you click and
drag a square and then you let go and
now we've zoomed
and as you can see the date has actually
changed with us but we can't really see
that so let's go over how to fix that if
you click on this configure sub plus
button it brings up this window here and
you can kind of manipulate how much
spacing there is on the side like you
could at zero and it would just go all
the way to the edge but we want to have
our labels seen so like you know that
looks pretty good like point zero seven
then on the bottom obviously we need
more so we're going to drag that up a
little bit and now you can see date
shows and then the right we can move it
over slightly and these two or more and
top you can bring up top we don't have a
title yet but we will have one soon but
since we don't have title we could drag
it all the way up or have it a little
bit of space there and then head space
in wit space or wide space I don't know
what it really needs horizontal element
anyway this is like space between the
like the tops of the charts so if you
have more than one plot you would want
to change this maybe but since we only
have one plot there's that it's not
going to do anything same thing with the
width space that's not going to do
anything but eventually it will do
something so you can kind of like
remember these numbers but we're going
to go through and hard-code it so every
time this chart comes up we don't like
set that stuff right that's kind of lame
so that's the next thing that we're
going to do but first let's go through a
couple more things with the chart so as
you can see like when we zoom in the
dates will change you know dynamically
and all this and let's say like you do
this and you're like oh my gosh this is
way too close like how do I get back to
where I was you can use these arrows to
get back and then you're like oh no I
wanted that one just prior you know you
can go back forward and so on the other
thing you can do is you can click on
this like I don't even know what it is
but it's so you can like kind of click
hold it and you can drag the chart
around so that's how you do that and
then if you just get so lost and all you
want to do is just get right back to
where you started you can hit this home
button and it takes you back home that's
just how to kind of navigate these
charts if you're unfamiliar with them
but generally what you want to do is
kind of code it in to display exactly
what you want but if it doesn't you can
so kind of go through and play with it
so anyway that's that so what we're
going to do now is let's do the subplot
stuff so the way that you do that is to
edit it you do PLT underscore penalty
dot subplots underscore adjust and in
here you put all those parameters that
we saw so there was like left bottom
white top W space in each space so let's
go ahead and define them all and you can
use that tool to figure out exactly what
you want or you can just kind of guess
and for us I'm pretty decent at it so we
should like with left we want to like at
n bottom we'll do point 19 right like
nine three top equals like point nine
five I think so once we throw in a title
we'll want to have that and W space
we're not really going to touch those
yet so I guess I guess we could code
them in but we're not we don't need them
yet
point twenty and then each space Oh
point zero seven something like that you
can adjust them like I said on your own
if you want so now let's add a title and
to do that we're going to use what's
called a super title or sup title and
for our title we want it to be whatever
the stock name is plus a space and then
a stock price so if we're doing like
Tesla it will say Tesla space stock
price so it kind of looks good so let's
save that and let's run it and sure
enough on pop-up this looks pretty darn
good
right the date is formatted nice and
neatly that stock price over here the
title is like perfect that was a good
guess yes so this chart is looking a lot
better right onload and what's nice
about it is what you can do later on is
instead of like loading up the chart in
this little like figure diagram you can
just automatically shoot it out to a
image like a PNG or you can do like a
tiff or whatever you want you can you
can have it come out as so it's
it's kind of helpful to have it like
already formatted just in case you don't
want to actually generate the chart
yourself and you just maybe want to
generate images real quick so um I think
that's going to include everything I
wanted to cover in this video
in the next video we'll be continuing
along here and I think when we go what
we're going to do in the next one is
like this is pretty amazing decent
enough we will get into doing like
candlestick and you can like change you
can change everything like you can
change the font you can change the
colors you can change the background
here you can change just everything like
all the line colors and the background
color of face color here in the
background here and everything can be
changed so there's a lot of
customization that can be done but and
we'll get into that because everybody
like with their financial charts they
got to be like badass looking right you
make more money if your chart looks
badass
so we definitely have to do that
eventually but first let's go ahead and
get the essentials down so in the next
video what we're going to do is start
plotting up volume data so what we want
to do you know you've got stock price up
here and then maybe down here you've got
volume right of that data so that'll be
the next thing that we do so if that
sounds interesting you carry on to the
next video as always thank you for
watching thank you for your support your
subscriptions and until next time